marty schottenheimer coach for 21 years
in the nfl with four different
franchises died monday at the age
of 77. washington
san diego cleveland kansas city
unbelievable two losing seasons in 21
years
you know we talk from time to time that
mike tomlin has never had a losing
season during his time
as the coach the steelers and people say
that in
kind of hushed reverential tones well 21
years in the nfl
and only two losing seasons with four
different teams four different
organizations
to go through four different teams and
only have two losing seasons
that's remarkable and eighth all time on
the wins list with 200
and a winning percentage of over 61
percent
200 126 and one there he is eighth on
the all-time
list and uh you know one of the guys who
was really you know from the mid 80s
into the middle part of the last decade
he was just part of the fabric of the
nfl period
part of the fabric of the nfl you talked
to any coach they'd go man you got to
play a marty schottenheimer team you
better be ready
you know detailed tough you know have
creativity
everything like that you know again you
know there's there's an issue here
there's an issue but why is he not in
the hall of fame
because he didn't win the super bowl i
mean that's that's all it comes down to
now that's all it is
i i don't understand that you know it's
eighth all time
teams are always awesome you just talked
about it 21 years
i know he didn't get to the super bowl
uh it's it's tough john elway ruined
that yeah the 98 yard drive
you know ernest beiner fumbled in a
walk-in touchdown i i mean again it's
sometimes it's bad luck in football i
don't know any other way to say it
but uh that i'm sick of that aspect of
the hall of fame i'm kind of sick of the
hall of fame altogether
but the like the dan reeves the marty
schottenheimer's of the world they got
to start getting more respect it's just
it's
ridiculous right now can we put the
graphic back up with the
all-time wins i'm just curious to see
how many of these names are going to
jump out as guys who are already in of
course shula halas
belichick will be landry is they all
yeah andy reed will be
right paul brown is chuck noll is dan
reeves should get there and and here's
where schottenheimer
reeves and other former coaches are
going to benefit
from the way that they've reconfigured
this hall of fame process it used to be
that coaches
were in that same bucket with the
players
where you had the five
modern era finalists every year you were
competing
with quarterbacks receivers running
backs defensive linemen everyone
to try to get one of those five seats
they have changed it now
because they have um
created a separate track every year
there's a spot for a coach
this year tom flores got that spot
and got in two super bowls he's finally
in
what the hell took so long but chris my
point is they have that
that track because he's not competing
with players
coaches aren't competing with players
anymore and coaches who have gotten in
like tony dungy had to get in as part of
this
this this quagmire of all different
shapes and sizes of players
you create the separate track dan reeves
marty schottenheimer
don coryell you're going to see guys get
in
that had been over yeah but these are
like guys that should be in go get there
i know i mean i guess i hope i guess but
they did you know the word quagmire
should not be talked about with the hall
of fame that just tells you
that too many non-hall of fame football
players are being put in the hall of
fame right now
that just tells you the hall of fame
used to be special
really really special it's watered down
right now i don't really want to say it
it's not the same it's it's it's now
it's become
you know it's political popular and you
know we'll figure out more ways to get
more guys in on every year basis and
to me it's lost its luster over the last
few years look look it's a museum in
ohio
that they want people to make a
destination and every august it becomes
the center of the nfl's universe
and the more guys who get in the bigger
the deal it is you can't have a year
where you look around and say well
there's no one worthy this year
let's just cancel the parade let's
cancel the ceremony
let's cancel the game we don't have
anyone worthy because i've made the
argument multiple times recently that
the mic drop that mike chapel did to get
peyton manning in where you have no
conversation no discussion no debate
maybe that's the bar maybe those are
only those are the only guys who should
get in
you shouldn't have this never-ending
hall of bust that's going to extend on
eventually forever
because you're putting eight guys in
every single year that's a different
issue altogether
my point is my point is coaches now have
that separate path yeah
and i think it's going to get now is it
always better for a guy to get in during
his lifetime
absolutely but i think that the the
problem will be rectified
by virtue of the fact that the hall of
fame has changed things up back to marty
schottenheimer let's do that look at
some of these losses
i know and and his his last
game yeah as a coach right
was that yeah marlon mccree marlon
mccree had the
interception of tom brady the game was
over
mccree fumbles the ball and that's that
and the patriots end up winning the game
and they go on to play the colts to next
weekend and i'm telling you the chargers
matched up very well with those peyton
manning teams oh and i think they could
they could have gone in well it would
have been indianapolis coming to san
diego not
the chargers going to indianapolis
because the
chargers were 14-2 that year they would
have had a very good chance of beating
the colts and it would have been
chargers bears
in super bowl 41. yeah it's a shame that
was a that's a tough one i mean
he's the king of tough playoff losses he
really is i mean
i've never saw a guy have more
heartbreaking gut-wrenching losses in
the playoffs
great coach i mean yeah those charge
that charger team was
was really damn good it really was i
mean it was a special special football
team there for
about a four or five year period it was
certainly one of the most talented teams
in football but
i again grew up in the era of marty
schottenheimer
i know he was a guy that when my dad had
to play the cleveland browns and
everything like that he
always knew they practiced and did
training camp against the browns
you know back in the day and i just
remember him always just oh man marty
schottenheimer
you know just he knew it was going to be
tough physical
i think in a lot of ways my dad was
happy the broncos won
you know the afc championship game i
think he was more and i don't
i'm not trying to disrespect anything
like that because i know my dad was you
know
crap scared of john elway and what he
can do but i think he was also very wary
of what the browns were and how they
matched up with his giants and how
marty schottenheimer his physical
football team and all that could be a
pain in the butt with two weeks to
prepare
so marty shot and humber great needs to
get in the hall of fame
all these guys got to get in the hall of
fame a little bit i'm sick of this stuff
dan reeves needs to be in the hall of
fame we can't do it after they pass away
that's not cool should have already been
in hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports